This idea that there's some road that I'm supposed to be following, or that I'm supposed to be creating, like, what will appear past that tree is what will appear, and I will be, and whatever it is, I will deal with it as gracefully as I can with enthusiasm, and what I get from that is what I put into it.
这种想法是，有一条路是我应该遵循的，或者是我应该创造的，比如，那棵树后面会出现什么，我就会出现什么，无论它是什么，我都会热情地尽可能优雅地处理它，我从中得到的就是我投入的。
and I'm trying to do that because I look back and I thought I was an engineer, I thought I was trying to go places, but that's not what was happening at all.
我正在尝试这样做，因为当我回顾过去时，我以为我是一名工程师，我以为我正在尝试去一些地方，但事实并非如此。
Things were given to me, the opportunities showed up and I did the best I could.
事情给了我，机会出现了，我尽了最大努力。
Welcome to a special bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》的特别奖励剧集。
I'm your producer, Alec Lev, and here's what happened.
我是你们的制片人，亚历克·列夫，事情是这样的。
We had wanted to speak with John Cho, the voice you just heard at the top.
我们想与约翰·赵（John Cho）交谈，他就是你刚刚在顶部听到的声音。
For our discussion of season 3, episode 6, I'm Not That Guy, in which John plays Jefferson Coatsworth, luring Marshall over to the dark side of Big Corporate Law and away from Marshall's dream job at the National Resource Defense Council.
在我们讨论第三季第六集《我不是那个人》时，约翰扮演杰斐逊·科茨沃斯，引诱马歇尔走向大公司法的黑暗面，并远离马歇尔在国家资源保护委员会的梦想工作。
We couldn't make our schedules work to have John join us for our recording, but then we were able to talk to him just a little while after that recording.
我们无法安排约翰加入我们的录音，但录音结束后不久我们就可以和他交谈。
And rather than just talk to him for a few minutes as planned, Josh, Craig, and John had a fantastic discussion that stretched out over half an hour.
乔什、克雷格和约翰并没有按计划只与他交谈几分钟，而是进行了长达半个多小时的精彩讨论。
We played to a segment of that interview in our full rewatch of episode six, but we can now present the full talk to you here.
我们在完整重播第六集时播放了该采访的一部分，但现在我们可以在这里向您展示完整的谈话内容。
Important to note, the New York Knicks had sadly just lost game three of the NBA finals the night before our chat.
值得注意的是，在我们聊天的前一天晚上，纽约尼克斯队遗憾地输掉了 NBA 总决赛的第三场比赛。
Go next and go John.
接下来是约翰。
I'm in my basement in Los Angeles, California.
我在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的地下室里。
Where are you guys?
你们在哪里？
It looks very New York with the brick.
砖块看起来很纽约。
We're in Cragton, Tribeca.
我们在翠贝卡的克拉格顿。
I'm in Fort Green in Brooklyn.
我在布鲁克林的格林堡。
We're we're East Coasters now.
我们现在是东海岸人了。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Oh, you're living.
哦，你还活着。
You're living the life you told.
你过着你所说的生活。
Yeah.
是的。
We pretended we were in New York for many years on stage 22 of the Fox lot, and then we decided maybe we should have we should live there.
我们假装自己在纽约福克斯电视台 22 号舞台上呆了很多年，然后我们决定也许我们应该住在那里。
We should see what this New York place is all about.
我们应该看看纽约这个地方到底是怎么回事。
Wow, that's wild.
哇，太疯狂了。
Hey, how's I got to ask just because I've been watching the finals.
嘿，我怎么就因为看了总决赛就问这个呢。
What's the vibe?
气氛如何？
Not just married today, but very spirited today.
今天不仅结婚了，而且今天还很精神。
Yeah, it's super fun.
是的，超级有趣。
There's like a dive bar down the block from me, and they put out a huge flat screen and and I was walking my dog and there were like 150 people just on the sidewalk sitting there.
离我不远的街区有一家潜水酒吧，他们放了一个巨大的平面屏幕，我正在遛狗，人行道上大约有 150 个人坐在那里。
That's so wild.
那太狂野了。
I wish I was there.
我希望我在那里。
I want to see it.
我想看看。
I honestly go on YouTube and type in Nick's fans going crazy.
老实说，我在 YouTube 上输入了疯狂的尼克粉丝的内容。
Yeah.
是的。
And I love to grab your joint where you can find it.
我喜欢在你能找到的地方抓住你的关节。
Yeah.
是的。
Are you in New York?
你在纽约吗？
John, why are you so attached to the next?
约翰，你为什么这么执着于下一个？
Or do you just like the NBA finals, whoever's it?
或者你只是喜欢 NBA 总决赛，不管是谁？
Where are you from?
你从哪来？
I don't even know.
我什至不知道。
I was born in Korea.
我出生在韩国。
I never lived in New York.
我从未在纽约住过。
You never lived in New York.
你从未在纽约住过。
I never lived in New York.
我从未在纽约住过。
And you know, I always wanted to, but every time I always say when I visit, I realize, well, in my 20s, when I was visiting, I was like, oh, it's good that I don't live here.
你知道，我一直想这么做，但每次我总是说，当我访问时，我意识到，好吧，在我 20 多岁的时候，当我访问时，我就想，哦，我不住在这里真好。
I think I might die from booze and drugs.
我想我可能会死于酗酒和吸毒。
Like when I was in my 20s, I felt like I would have gotten into so much trouble.
就像我20多岁的时候一样，我觉得我会遇到很多麻烦。
Yeah, there's too much to do.
是的，有太多事情要做。
Don't you think LA keeps you just on the side of safer because you have to drive?
您是否不认为洛杉矶让您更安全，因为您必须开车？
I do.
我愿意。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like New York is you can get everywhere without getting behind a wheel.
就像纽约一样，您无需开车即可到达任何地方。
Yeah.
是的。
And that four AM thing versus two AM, those are two huge hours.
凌晨四点和凌晨两点，那是两个重要的小时。
It's good to shut down it too.
关闭它也很好。
There was some real how I made your mother wisdom in that.
我确实让你母亲在这方面变得明智。
Yeah, we did an episode in season one called Nothing Good Happens After 2 AM.
是的，我们在第一季做了一集，名为《凌晨 2 点之后没有什么好事发生》。
Like that was the title of the episode and it's, you, that's exactly what you're saying and it's true.
就像这集的标题一样，你，这正是你所说的，这是真的。
It's so true.
这是真的。
I was like, wow, these hours matter.
我当时想，哇，这些时间很重要。
These hours very much matter.
这些时间非常重要。
These hours matter.
这些时间很重要。
They're consequential hours.
它们是重要的时间。
Highly consequential, man.
非常重要，伙计。
Well, we're so happy you could join us.
嗯，我们很高兴你能加入我们。
Oh, thanks.
哦，谢谢。
We had so much fun re-watching this episode.
我们重温这一集非常有趣。
Did you have a chance to re-watch it?
你有机会再看一遍吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
You're so funny at it, John.
你真是太有趣了，约翰。
You were so funny in that episode.
那一集你真是太搞笑了。
That's why we felt like we had to steal you and talk to you for a minute.
这就是为什么我们觉得我们必须偷走你并与你交谈一分钟。
Oh, my gosh.
哦，天哪。
We talked about this episode in the way that we sort of normally do where we go through it and we're like, John's so funny in this episode and you kind of hijack all those scenes that you're in this great way.
我们以我们通常经历的方式谈论这一集，我们就像，约翰在这一集里太有趣了，你以这种很棒的方式劫持了所有那些场景。
And now we're like, we gotta talk to John.
现在我们想，我们得和约翰谈谈。
So anyway.
所以无论如何。
You're very sweet.
你很可爱。
My, I did really watch it and I was like, one, I was like, this is such sharp writing.
天啊，我真的看了它，我想，一，我想，这真是犀利的写作。
There's so many joke handles all the time.
总是有很多笑话。
She's like, okay, and there's so many joke rums to hang on to at each corner.
她说，好吧，每个角落都有很多笑话朗姆酒可以抓住。
It's very dense.
非常浓密。
I like the way I'm saying it, there's joke right.
我喜欢我说话的方式，这是个笑话。
That's sort of like you felt like it was something to grab onto with each line.
这有点像你觉得每一行都有值得抓住的东西。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I can see you doing that because you just so nail each line and each line has its own take and journey in the way that you do it.
我可以看到你这样做，因为你把每一行都钉牢了，每行都有自己的方式和旅程。
And I like getting a peek in your brain of how that's how you see it.
我喜欢看看你的大脑是如何看待它的。
You know, I got the feeling, cause I wasn't, it's so weird.
你知道，我有这种感觉，因为我没有，这太奇怪了。
Cause I don't have, I was like, I don't have a strong memory of John being on set.
因为我没有，我当时想，我对约翰在片场的记忆并不深刻。
I was like, we didn't have any scenes together.
我当时想，我们没有任何一起的场景。
We didn't have scenes together.
我们没有一起拍戏。
That's right.
这是正确的。
That'll do it.
这样就可以了。
But I got the feeling like you were really enjoying the mix of getting to be both charming and evil seemed like something you were enjoying playing.
但我感觉你真的很享受变得迷人和邪恶的结合，这似乎是你喜欢玩的东西。
I do like that.
我确实喜欢这样。
Okay.
好的。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It's a good one.
这是一件好事。
I do enjoy being a douche.
我确实很享受当混蛋的感觉。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, sometimes I feel like you and I have both been asked to be like the virtuous center of things.
好吧，有时我觉得你和我都被要求成为事物的良性中心。
Right.
正确的。
And then when you get to be on the side and be like a little more yago or a little more crazy, it's fun.
然后，当你站在一边，表现得更加yago或者更加疯狂时，那就很有趣了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Is Iago, that's a character from Jeff Fox or what they show right.
是伊阿古吗，那是杰夫·福克斯的一个角色，或者他们所表现的正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
I do like that.
我确实喜欢这样。
I was gonna, the, the, I think also the density.
我本来打算，这个，这个，我想还有密度。
May I propose a theory?
我可以提出一个理论吗？
We love theories here because I didn't know.
我们喜欢这里的理论，因为我不知道。
I don't know why I didn't know.
我不知道为什么我不知道。
I didn't know you guys didn't use a studio audience.
我不知道你们没有使用演播室观众。
Oh, like did you show up to the experience thinking this isn't this there's going to be a well look at that bleachers yes that's what I'd come from and I was like oh they don't do this and I and I think I was thirsty for laughs from the studio audience and it was in some ways like I was Because after I did, you know, Josh, I did the year on the sitcom.
哦，就像你出现在体验中时，认为这不是这个，会好好看看那个看台，是的，这就是我来自的地方，我想哦，他们不这样做，我和我想我渴望演播室观众的笑声，在某些方面就像我一样，因为在我这样做之后，你知道，乔什，我在情景喜剧中做了一年。
And I came off of that going, I shouldn't do these anymore.
我摆脱了这种状态，我不应该再做这些了。
I don't think it's good for me because I was such a flower.
我不认为这对我有什么好处，因为我是一朵花。
Yes.
是的。
This is our theory that we share this theory.
这是我们的理论，我们共享这个理论。
I was bending towards the light all the time.
我一直向着光弯腰。
It warps your performance in a lot of ways.
它会在很多方面扭曲你的表现。
It cranks you up and you're trying to get laughter from people that they're tossing candy to.
它让你兴奋起来，你试图让那些正在向他们扔糖果的人笑起来。
Yes.
是的。
And we always thought like you do the run through for the crew, the crew really laughs the first time you do it, but the cameras aren't rolling, right?
我们一直认为，就像你为剧组人员进行演练一样，当你第一次这样做时，剧组人员真的笑了，但摄像机没有滚动，对吧？
So then once the cameras start rolling, you just have to depend on your own sense of like comedy, but also truth.
因此，一旦摄像机开始转动，你就只能依靠自己对喜剧的感觉，但也要依靠事实。
And I think it kept us like more subtle and more grounded even though they were piping left.
我认为这让我们变得更加微妙和更加脚踏实地，尽管他们已经离开了。
I agree.
我同意。
And then really to the density comment, I feel like you could layer in more because you could keep it in rhythm.
然后，对于密度评论，我觉得你可以分层更多，因为你可以保持节奏。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
of like being busted up by the laughs.
就像被笑声打倒了一样。
And that's the thing about the studio audience too.
这也是演播室观众的问题。
It's like, you want the laughs and it feels great to get a laugh.
就像，你想要笑声，而得到笑声的感觉很棒。
And then you do, on the third take, they go, oh, that didn't get as much of a laugh.
然后，在第三次拍摄时，他们会说，哦，这并没有引起太多笑声。
We should rewrite the joke.
我们应该重写这个笑话。
And then people huddle up and they try and beat the joke.
然后人们挤在一起，试图打破这个笑话。
And I was like, I guess that made sense at the time, but looking back, I'm like, it did work.
我当时想，我想这在当时是有道理的，但回想起来，我想，它确实有效。
I know, it doesn't really make sense.
我知道，这确实没有意义。
It doesn't really make sense.
这确实没有意义。
It's like, you might get another decent joke, but it doesn't mean the one that they heard for the third time it didn't laugh is now bad.
就像，你可能会得到另一个像样的笑话，但这并不意味着他们第三次听到但没有笑的笑话现在很糟糕。
It's just, it is a weird brain thing that happened to that.
只是，这件事发生在大脑中很奇怪。
The alternate joke is typically not as on story.
另一个笑话通常并不像故事中那样。
It felt like, I know it's real, but it's not.
感觉就像，我知道这是真的，但事实并非如此。
It's just to, it's a freestanding joke.
只是，这只是一个独立的笑话。
It's a freestanding joke.
这是一个独立的笑话。
Shocked the audience back to life.
震撼观众起死回生。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
That's right, that's a good way to put it, Josh.
是的，这是一个很好的表达方式，乔什。
Just to fill in our history, so the very first pilot I ever did, and I've talked about this a lot on the show, what's this white's brothers danny zukershow called off center that you were on and we so we work together i mean this was two thousand one i think that's like like spring of two thousand ones is a long time ago but uh...
只是为了填补我们的历史，所以我做过的第一个飞行员，我在节目中谈论了很多，这个怀特的兄弟丹尼·祖克秀称你在节目中偏离了中心，所以我们一起工作我的意思是这是两千零一我认为这就像两千零一的春天是很久以前的事了但是呃......
we spent a week or two together shooting this thousand it was because we went one season on that show and in two thousand it anyway it i was on that show when the towers went down right because I think it was the spring of 2001 and then you guys would have started production and then right around then like a month later or something in the tower.
我们花了一两周的时间一起拍摄这一千部，因为我们在那部剧上演了一季，而在两千部里，无论如何，当塔楼倒塌时我正在那个节目中，因为我认为那是2001年春天，然后你们就开始制作，然后大约一个月后或者塔楼里的什么东西。
Hey, I brought up 9-11.
嘿，我提到了 9-11。
You win, we have a prize for some of my first one to bring it up.
你赢了，我们对第一个提出这个问题的人有奖。
But I'll check my mailbox.
不过我会检查一下我的邮箱。
And then I got replaced on the show and it was this kind of devastating thing for me because it was my first pilot in not just in LA and show business.
然后我在节目中被替换，这对我来说是毁灭性的事情，因为这是我的第一个试播集，不仅仅是在洛杉矶和演艺界。
but it really, you know, it kind of gave me this sense of like resilience.
但它确实给了我一种坚韧的感觉。
Like I needed, I mean, every actor needs, you know, you take these knocks, but I had a great time with you and the whole cast and- I remember being like, I was like, okay, he's gonna be okay.
就像我需要的那样，我的意思是，每个演员都需要，你知道，你要承受这些打击，但我和你以及整个演员一起度过了一段美好的时光，而且 - 我记得我当时想，好吧，他会没事的。
I gotta say, at the time, it freaked me out, like going, oh, so this is possible.
我得说，当时，它吓坏了我，就像去，哦，所以这是可能的。
So this happens, like you can be good and still have this happen.
所以这种情况就会发生，就像你可以表现得很好一样，但这种情况仍然会发生。
It's like you're a, you know, you're a doctor knows conference table and you see a guy go in the trap door and you go, there are trap doors here?
就好像你是一个，你知道，你是一个医生知道的会议桌，你看到一个人走进活板门，然后你走了，这里有活板门？
You know, I'm this conference table.
你知道，我就是这张会议桌。
And that's, I don't mean to make light of what happened to you.
也就是说，我并不是要轻视发生在你身上的事情。
It was like, wow, okay, so that's what we're in.
就像，哇，好吧，这就是我们所处的情况。
You know what helped me that I thought about at the time, but this great director, I worked with David Warren, his husband is a guy named Peter Fershet, who's one of the best stage actors I've ever seen.
你知道我当时想到的是什么对我有帮助，但是这位伟大的导演，我和大卫·沃伦一起工作，他的丈夫是一个叫彼得·费谢特的人，他是我见过的最好的舞台演员之一。
And he didn't, he did a lot of TV.
但他没有，他拍了很多电视节目。
And David told me he got fired after the table read of a pilot.
大卫告诉我，在表格上显示一名飞行员后，他被解雇了。
And I was like, Peter got fired.
我当时想，彼得被解雇了。
And he looked at me.
他看着我。
I remember he goes, everyone gets fired.
我记得他走了，每个人都被解雇了。
Wow.
哇。
It was like, everyone gets fired.
就像，每个人都被解雇了。
It's not a thing.
这不是一件事。
It's just a thing, you know?
这只是一件事，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
And I was really comforted by that.
我对此感到非常安慰。
And also the list of famous people who've been fired from pilots is impressive.
被飞行员解雇的名人名单也令人印象深刻。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
It's very impressive.
这是非常令人印象深刻的。
It's a glorious list.
这是一份光荣的清单。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目。
It's funny how long I've known you.
有趣的是我认识你多久了。
I mean, we were babies, you know.
我的意思是，我们还是婴儿，你知道。
Was that your first series?
那是你的第一个系列吗？
Yes, it was.
是的，确实如此。
By the way, I mean, that was the other super depressing part of watching this.
顺便说一句，我的意思是，这是观看此视频的另一个超级令人沮丧的部分。
Show this episode was like because that was like before I had kids and I was like wow become an old belt in the intervening years But the but it was a long time ago as it turns out.
显示这一集就像是因为那就像在我有孩子之前，我就像哇，在这几年里变成了一条老腰带，但事实证明，那是很久以前的事了。
Yeah, well, but this would this is 18 years ago this episode 18 years is is an actual length of life.
是的，好吧，但这已经是 18 年前的事了，这一集 18 年是真实的生命长度。
Yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, yeah, so it was right before, it would have been right before my son was born who just graduated from high school.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，所以就在之前，就在我刚刚高中毕业的儿子出生之前。
So it's like, it was a wild to see just the before Polaroid.
所以，看到之前的宝丽来照片真是太疯狂了。
We're experiencing that a weekly on this podcast.
我们每周都会在这个播客上体验这一点。
You're welcome to our home because we're right there with you.
欢迎您来到我们家，因为我们就在您身边。
We're kids, man, but that's really funny, John.
我们还是孩子，伙计，但这真的很有趣，约翰。
So you showed up to this thing and you go, wait, no audience, were you rattled by that?
所以你出现在这件事上，然后你走了，等等，没有观众，你对此感到不安吗？
Were you disappointed that that?
你对此感到失望吗？
I'm first of all, I'm sorry we didn't explain that to you when we offered you the part.
首先，我很抱歉，当我们向您提供该零件时，我们没有向您解释这一点。
I've been meaning to write you a letter.
我一直想给你写一封信。
What?
什么？
Sadly, were you like, throttled for a second?
可悲的是，你是否像，节流了一秒钟？
But then you kind of said, wait, no, this is what I wanted because you were suspicious of the audience from having done that show a few years earlier.
但后来你有点说，等等，不，这就是我想要的，因为你对几年前看过那个节目的观众表示怀疑。
And you were like, I think this is making me thirsty for the audience, which I think is such a real thing.
你说，我认为这让我渴望观众，我认为这是真实的事情。
And my feeling of you on how I met your mother as you came in and because you had done so much film and you were so funny and so like we were just fans of yours and so many different movie parts, including Harold and Kumar, where like we cast Neil because of him coming in and hijacking his scenes in that movie.
当你进来时，我对你的感觉是，我是如何遇见你母亲的，因为你拍了这么多电影，你很有趣，就像我们只是你的粉丝，还有很多不同的电影角色，包括哈罗德和库马尔，就像我们选尼尔一样，因为他进来并劫持了他在那部电影中的场景。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And like, and you were so fucking funny in that movie and Cal, we had Cal on the show many seasons later.
就像，你在那部电影和卡尔中真是太有趣了，很多季后我们让卡尔出现在节目中。
So we've had both of you guys on the show.
所以我们让你们俩都参加了演出。
You seemed to me and tell me if I'm right to pretty immediately tune into like, okay, this is more like we're making a little movie.
在我看来，你告诉我我是否正确，立即调整为，好吧，这更像是我们在拍一部小电影。
I get to do these fun, weird scenes where I'm seducing and mind fucking Jason Siegel.
我会拍这些有趣、奇怪的场景，在这些场景中我会引诱并介意他妈的杰森·西格尔。
Did you settle in and it sort of felt okay, not to have that audience pretty quickly or whatever reason.
你是否适应了，感觉还不错，但很快就没有观众了，或者什么原因。
I think I got adjusted pretty quick.
我想我很快就适应了。
My scenes were with Jason.
我的场景是和杰森在一起的。
It's all about your scene partner, right?
这都是关于你的场景伙伴的，对吧？
And Jason, I do remember at the time and in retrospect, I was reminded like I was really kind of amazed his chops and he's you know coming from like the sitcom background you know even during Harold and Kumar I was like I got it I think I'm still listening for the studio audience you know every time I was doing a comedy yeah I really it took out in your so many years for me to be able to do comedy and be interior you know and be inside and not watching myself in a mirror all the time.
杰森，我确实记得当时，回想起来，我被提醒说我真的很惊讶他的能力，你知道他来自就像你知道的情景喜剧背景，即使在哈罗德和库马尔期间，我就像我明白了，我想我仍然在倾听演播室观众的声音，你知道，每次我拍喜剧是的，我真的在你这么多年里，我能够拍喜剧，保持内心，你知道，在里面，而不是一直在镜子里看着自己。
Comedy specifically, you know what I mean?
特别是喜剧，你知道我的意思吗？
Because of the laughs.
因为笑声。
And I do recall, like Jason just was such a natural, he was so funny and he didn't seem like he was doing anything.
我确实记得，杰森是如此自然，他是如此有趣，而且他看起来并没有在做任何事情。
He was just like, he just like walked in and was funny and charming and knew his lines.
他就像走进来一样，很有趣，很有魅力，而且知道他的台词。
And I was like, how is this happening?
我当时想，这是怎么发生的？
Like, it felt like I was like, ah, you know, all the time.
就像，我感觉就像，啊，你知道，一直如此。
And he was like, you know.
他就像，你知道。
Oh, well, you don't come across that way in this episode.
哦，好吧，在这一集中你不会遇到这种情况。
No, no, no, not at all.
不，不，不，一点也不。
You feel that way.
你有这样的感觉。
You're very subtle and nuanced in your seduction of blurring him in.
你在诱惑他的过程中非常微妙，细致入微。
It's a very funny performance that builds all through the episode.
这是贯穿整集的非常有趣的表演。
I just watched it today again.
我今天刚刚又看了一遍。
You're so good in it.
你太擅长了。
Oh, thanks.
哦，谢谢。
I think I've been thinking about that experience since because I go, is, you know, because I like watching sitcoms.
我想我一直在思考那段经历，因为我去，你知道，因为我喜欢看情景喜剧。
And yet that I see sitcoms.
但我还是看情景喜剧。
I see people, what happened to me, I can see it on the screen with people.
我看到人们，发生在我身上的事情，我可以在屏幕上看到人们。
And I go, how come they don't do this more?
我想，他们为什么不再这样做呢？
This is like a real, I'm shocked that people don't occupy this lane much now.
这就像真实的一样，令我震惊的是现在人们很少占用这条巷子。
Greg, I don't know, has any sitcom shot the way we shot?
格雷格，我不知道，有没有情景喜剧是按照我们的方式拍摄的？
I think every year, many sitcoms would try it because I would get phone calls being like, how did you guys do it?
我想每年都有很多情景喜剧会尝试它，因为我会接到电话，问我，你们是怎么做到的？
And I'd sort of explained it, and so would Pam Fryman.
我对此进行了解释，帕姆·弗莱曼也会如此。
Pam Fryman would be hired to go direct other ones like that.
帕姆·弗莱曼将被聘请来指导其他类似的事情。
And there was something about the specific alchemy of what we had there with that cast, with the wonderful Josh Radner, with the wonderful Jason Segal.
我们与演员阵容、精彩的乔什·拉德纳和精彩的杰森·西格尔一起，有一些特殊的炼金术。
And that crew, whatever that just bizarre alchemical mix was something about that is very hard to replicate.
还有那个船员，无论这种奇怪的炼金术组合是什么，都是很难复制的。
I don't know what else to say.
我不知道还能说什么。
I think also though, you made it, The way you and Carter wrote the show with 40 to 60 scenes, you made it logistically impossible to do, like- It was rigorous.
我也认为，你做到了，你和卡特用 40 到 60 个场景编写这部剧的方式，你让它在逻辑上不可能做到，就像——它是严格的。
Yeah, and we had a crew that was up for it.
是的，我们有一支做好准备的工作人员。
Yeah, it was all editing.
是的，这一切都是编辑的。
We wrote it as editing jokes.
我们把它写成编辑笑话。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
One of my favorite jokes, John, is we meet your character and he's smooth and swab, he's cool, he's playing Marshall.
约翰，我最喜欢的笑话之一是我们见到了你的角色，他很光滑，很酷，他在扮演马歇尔。
And immediately we flash forward and spoil that he's evil by saying, well, this is what happened to him And there you are being perp walked out of a corner.
我们立即闪现并破坏他的邪恶，说，好吧，这就是发生在他身上的事情，而你正被从角落里走出来。
And you said on the perp walk, I wrote down what you said because you're so funny with it.
你在罪犯散步时说，我写下了你所说的话，因为你对此很有趣。
You say, you all go to hell.
你说，你们都下地狱吧。
I didn't, he said, you all go to hell.
我没有，他说，你们都下地狱吧。
I do it again.
我再做一次。
I'm innocent.
我是无辜的。
I do it again.
我再做一次。
Then I'm innocent all in one breath.
那我一口气就清白了。
And I was like, we have, it felt very prophetic of where we are now.
我当时想，我们已经做到了，这感觉非常预示着我们现在所处的位置。
I'm going to refrain from talking about current events right now.
我现在不会谈论时事。
I know me too.
我也认识我。
help and think about it watching this episode.
帮忙看一下这一集并思考一下。
We also really loved your public school joke.
我们也很喜欢你的公立学校笑话。
That was the one that made me laugh.
那是让我发笑的一个。
What was the public school joke?
公立学校的笑话是什么？
The kids who walk out, they walk out proud.
走出去的孩子们，他们自豪地走出去。
The kids who walk out.
走出去的孩子们。
It's so said that every single thing is backhanded and there's just it's so manipulative and every line has a deeper ulterior motive, but you're very charming with all of it.
都说每件事都是反手的，而且都是那么的操纵性，每一句台词都有更深的不可告人的目的，但你却非常有魅力。
It's really funny.
真的很有趣。
Well, it was the smile, the smile was on the page, it really was, that was, that was really great stuff.
嗯，是微笑，微笑就在纸上，真的是，那是，那真是很棒的东西。
I was like, these are great lines.
我当时想，这些都是很棒的台词。
The other, the other thing that I had forgotten was the sheer number of scenes.
另一件我忘记的事情是场景的数量。
I was like, how did they do this?
我当时想，他们是怎么做到的？
This is a, this is a three week shoot, you know, I couldn't believe it.
这是一个为期三周的拍摄，你知道，我简直不敢相信。
And because my memory was that it was really relaxed.
因为我的记忆是真的很放松。
In fact, I've done very few shows where I'm coming into a multi...
事实上，我很少参加多场演出……
In my whole career, I think I've done maybe three shows where I've done an episode of anything that's season three and beyond.
在我的整个职业生涯中，我想我可能已经完成了三部节目，其中我已经完成了第三季及以后的任何剧集。
And it's a special feeling to walk onto a set like that where you go, and this is what I miss about shooting about the old days, when you're doing an L.A.
走进这样的片场是一种特别的感觉，这就是我怀念过去拍摄洛杉矶的时光。
crew, especially, can I just give my props to L.A.
特别是工作人员，我可以把我的道具交给洛杉矶吗？
Cruz?
克鲁兹？
I mean, 100, yeah.
我的意思是，100，是的。
The level of professionalism, just people.
专业水平，只是人。
So many people on the crew were multi-generation, you know, in their jobs and stuff.
你知道，剧组里的很多人在他们的工作和其他事情上都是好几代人。
Like, they were just like, the father is from.
就像，他们就像，父亲来自。
Cheers, we had people that like traced back.
干杯，我们找到了喜欢的人。
Oh yeah, we had people that really connected you to sitcom royalty, a lot of these guys, yeah.
哦，是的，我们有人真正将你与情景喜剧皇室联系起来，其中很多人，是的。
And when you walk onto a set like that and things are just smooth and running, right.
当你走进这样的片场时，事情就变得很顺利，对吧。
and nobody's getting, nobody's shouting, nobody's freaking out, they're just making stuff happen.
没有人明白，没有人大喊大叫，没有人惊慌失措，他们只是让事情发生。
It's so special.
太特别了。
Craig hasn't Pam brought a huge amount of the Hymium crew with her for the last decade?
克雷格在过去的十年里不是帕姆带来了大量的 Hymium 工作人员吗？
Yeah, they all worked together a lot, and even if it's not Pam on every episode, that crew is there, Chris Harris on the Frasier reboot had Susie Greenberg, our producer, and that brought in a huge amount of our production staff and crew.
是的，他们都一起工作了很多，即使不是每集都不是帕姆，剧组人员也在那里，《欢乐一家亲》重启的克里斯·哈里斯有我们的制片人苏西·格林伯格，这给我们带来了大量的制作人员和剧组人员。
Those folks really like to stick together, because there is something about those ingredients together.
这些人真的很喜欢粘在一起，因为这些成分在一起有一些东西。
There's something about it.
有一些关于它的事情。
And it turns out to be really hard to replicate.
事实证明，它确实很难复制。
And I know because Carter and I tried and failed several times after how much mother ended to try to recapture that.
我知道，因为在母亲竭尽全力试图重新夺回这一点之后，卡特和我尝试了好几次，但都失败了。
And we didn't.
但我们没有。
There's also something that calms an actor when you know the crew has got it.
当你知道剧组已经掌握了某些东西时，还有一种东西可以让演员平静下来。
We've all done the indies where you're like, it's chaos.
我们都做过独立游戏，你会觉得那里很混乱。
And you pick up on that.
你注意到了这一点。
When a crew is on top of things, it allows the whole set to relax and then you can do better work.
当一个团队掌控一切时，整个团队都会放松下来，然后你就能做得更好。
Yeah, I totally agree.
是的，我完全同意。
It's like, I always feel like when you're working with a great crew and a great director, and assured people who are assured, it's like being told a story by your mom or dad at bedtime, that kind of like I'm safe here.
就好像，我总觉得，当你和一个伟大的团队、一个伟大的导演，以及那些有信心的人一起工作时，就像你的妈妈或爸爸在睡前给你讲故事一样，就像我在这里很安全一样。
I'm safe here and I can just relax and enjoy this.
我在这里很安全，我可以放松并享受这一切。
thing.
事物。
So I really, that was my emotional memory of just going, wow, this is a really special experience walking into this kind of process.
所以我真的，这就是我的情感记忆，哇，这是进入这种过程的一次非常特殊的经历。
I'm so glad it felt that way.
我很高兴有这样的感觉。
We were so happy to have you there.
我们很高兴你能来。
You did get to play this wonderfully malevolent, this very charmingly, smoothly malevolent character.
你确实扮演了这个极其恶毒、非常迷人、流畅的恶毒角色。
Is it fun?
好玩吗？
I mean, you and Josh were starting to talk about that kind of before we even start really talking, but like, is it fun to play that sort of, that sort of a guy, like you get, you get to just be this person that you're, you're not in life, like when else when you get to be able this way, is there something cathartic about that?
我的意思是，在我们真正开始交谈之前，你和乔什就开始谈论这一点了，但是，扮演那样的人很有趣吗？就像你所得到的那样，你只能成为你自己，你不在生活中，就像其他时候，当你能够以这种方式时，这有什么宣泄的作用吗？
Like, when you're playing a good guy, you know, I think people assume that you're mining yourself.
就像，当你扮演一个好人时，我认为人们会认为你在挖掘自己。
And when you're playing a bad that guy, people assume that you're not minding yourself.
当你扮演一个坏人时，人们会认为你不介意自己。
Right, fair point.
正确的，公平的观点。
But you are.
但你是。
Right, yeah, because it's all we're all.
是的，是的，因为这就是我们的全部。
Well, it's all the same.
好吧，都是一样的。
It kind of like gives your shadow a chance to come out and play.
这有点像给你的影子一个出来玩耍的机会。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Well, you get to like say and do the things that are not, you would not do this in life, but they're in there or you wouldn't be able to play them.
好吧，你会喜欢说和做那些不存在的事情，你在生活中不会这样做，但它们就在那里，否则你将无法玩它们。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
This episode has one of the lines that gets, that I get on the street, the Kobe beef line.
这一集有一条我在街上经常听到的台词，神户牛肉台词。
Cobay B.
科贝 B.
Cobay Lobster.
科贝龙虾。
Cobay Lobster is Lobster.
科贝龙虾就是龙虾。
Is it at East Cobay B?
是在East Cobay B吗？
Is there a funny way you said that line was extraordinary?
你说那条线非同寻常，有什么有趣的方式吗？
John, because I wasn't on set when you guys were shooting this, I felt like when I watched this, I didn't even know if, because I didn't watch all the episodes, but I really felt like I was watching it like totally fresh, and I found your performance to be completely delightful, and I could tell that you were enjoying it, and I think it's good, I think it's actually good and healthy to enjoy playing evil because then we don't do evil.
约翰，因为你们拍摄这个的时候我不在片场，我觉得当我看这个的时候，我什至不知道是不是，因为我没有看所有的剧集，但我真的感觉我在看它，就像完全新鲜一样，我发现你的表演非常令人愉快，我可以看出你很享受它，我认为这很好，我认为享受扮演邪恶实际上是好的和健康的，因为这样我们就不会做坏事。
Like we get it out of our system.
就像我们把它从我们的系统中取出一样。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Oh my, yes, dude, yes, yes.
噢，天哪，是的，伙计，是的，是的。
Everyone should just, in a low stakes, I don't wanna get topical again, but people should get their evil out of their systems in non-consequential ways.
每个人都应该，在低风险的情况下，我不想再次成为话题，但人们应该以无关紧要的方式将他们的邪恶从他们的系统中消除。
Just do up-right-to-do-desin-super-gate and just get your evil out.
只要做正确的设计超级门，就把你的邪恶赶出去。
Non-consequential ways, key ones, non-consequential ways.
非重要的方式，关键的方式，非重要的方式。
But yeah, that was fun.
但是，是的，那很有趣。
all these like that company that Marshall gets sucked into that you seduce him into working for.
所有这些就像马歇尔被你引诱进入的那家公司一样。
And like, we have this like Barney by like Neil's character Barney.
就像，我们有像尼尔的角色巴尼这样的巴尼。
Like we keep thinking of Barney and of the company Barney works for the company this evil off from that you that your character worked for.
就像我们一直在想着巴尼和巴尼工作的公司一样，这与你的角色所工作的公司是邪恶的。
It just, it's hard not to think of where we are in 2026.
只是，我们很难不去思考 2026 年我们所处的位置。
You know, as we take stock of life 18 years later.
你知道，当我们回顾 18 年后的生活时。
Yeah.
是的。
It is hard to go there.
去那里很难。
It's not a political podcast, but yeah.
这不是政治播客，但是是的。
But even the, I think part of the stickiness of the Kobe Blobster line is how far we've gone with consumer access, like that seems.
但即便如此，我认为Kobe Blobster系列的粘性部分在于我们在消费者访问方面走了多远，就像看起来的那样。
And I think part of that has been building since the 90s.
我认为其中一部分自 20 世纪 90 年代以来就一直在建设。
Like this, this idea of more and more, how extreme can you make it?
这样，这种越来越多的想法，你能做到什么程度呢？
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
It's such a wonderful shorthand for what that is to me.
这是对我来说如此美妙的简写。
It is funny how with your character, John, and with Barney, you guys were parodying a kind of corporate slash political villain that was really broadly drawn and quite absurd in 2008 and is now like just normal.
有趣的是，你们扮演的约翰和巴尼，是在戏仿一种企业斜线政治恶棍，这种恶棍在 2008 年曾被广泛描绘，而且相当荒谬，现在却变得很正常。
Like it's so crazy to get topical, but it's funny that.
好像成为话题是如此疯狂，但很有趣。
John, I have this thing where I keep telling Craig that him and Carter have these weird prophetic moments.
约翰，我一直告诉克雷格，他和卡特有这些奇怪的预言时刻。
Like there's an episode in 2007 where Robin talks about subprime lenders.
就像 2007 年有一集罗宾谈论次级贷款机构一样。
Really?
真的吗？
And this is before 2008, before the crash.
这是 2008 年之前的事，也就是金融危机之前。
Like what were the other prophecies that were like, There was one other weird one, Craig.
就像其他预言一样，还有一个奇怪的预言，克雷格。
I wish we kept a lesson for getting right now.
我希望我们现在能吸取教训。
Alec, chime in if you remember.
亚历克，如果你还记得的话请插话。
There are.
有。
Trying to remember, sorry.
努力回忆，抱歉。
I'm working in.
我在工作。
I'm working in my head right now.
我现在正在脑子里工作。
I respect you that you came on, even though you don't have the answer.
我尊重你，尽管你没有答案。
Yeah.
是的。
Good to see you.
很高兴见到你。
I was like, he's coming on because he knows the answer.
我当时想，他上场是因为他知道答案。
Yeah, I felt it was a very confident appearance to not have the answer.
是的，我觉得没有答案是一种非常自信的表现。
All right.
好的。
No reason to be here.
没有理由来这里。
Bye.
再见。
But I missed you.
但我想念你。
I'll think of it.
我会考虑一下。
Keep going.
继续前进。
You're right that That guy seems plausible in a way that it didn't be for Yeah, it felt like I mean in some ways you could make the argument like it's less funny now because it's like No, it's like too too close, but it was still hilarious.
你是对的，那个家伙在某种程度上似乎是合理的，但事实并非如此，是的，我的意思是，在某些方面，你可以让这场争论变得不那么有趣，因为它就像不，它太接近了，但它仍然很搞笑。
It's gonna be fun.
这会很有趣。
Yeah How gentle it is you're almost Paternal yes, right.
是啊，你真是太温柔了，几乎就像父亲一样，是的，对吧。
Yeah, it's hey buddy.
是的，嘿，伙计。
Hey buddy.
嘿伙计。
It's just it's like yeah, you know what we're gonna that you take over the tuck-a-ho funland account, it's going to be great.
就像是的，你知道我们要做什么，你接管了 tuck-a-ho funland 帐户，那会很棒。
It's all so gentle.
一切都是那么温柔。
I think you just activated a memory for me.
我想你刚刚激活了我的记忆。
I think the part of that was like, you know, Jason's so tall.
我想那部分就像，你知道，杰森太高了。
He's like, he's a big guy.
他就像，他是一个大人物。
And I think at the time, I thought it's funny to talk like that to a guy who's so much bigger than I am.
我想当时我觉得和一个比我大得多的人这样说话很有趣。
It's funny.
很有趣。
It's really funny.
真的很有趣。
He's this big glued but you're like hey buddy yeah yeah you take him to the ferris wheel he's like a little kid he's got a corn dog and you have on the ferris wheel and you're like oh this can be yours buddy I don't have a memory we didn't shoot that off site that was on the back I think we've had a ferris wheel like a hundred feet from our sand stitch ladies and gentlemen Hollywood because it's all shot from below and you're kind of not very wide it's it was very a Hollywood.
他是如此大，但你就像嘿，伙计，是的，你带他去摩天轮，他就像一个小孩子，他有一只玉米热狗，你在摩天轮上，你就像哦，这可以是你的伙计，我不记得我们没有在背面拍摄那个摩天轮，我想我们有一个摩天轮，距离我们的沙缝好莱坞女士们先生们有一百英尺，因为它都是从下面拍摄的你的视野不是很宽，这是非常好莱坞的。
I think it was like in a parking spot practically somewhere on one of the little side roads of the Fox lot.
我认为这就像在福克斯停车场的一条小路的某个地方的停车位。
We didn't go anywhere.
我们哪儿也没去。
We rented that first wheel, I think.
我想我们租了第一个轮子。
It looked really good.
看起来真的很好。
God bless Pam.
上帝保佑帕姆。
Again, our amazing crew and Pam Friman.
再次感谢我们出色的工作人员和帕姆·弗里曼。
It looked great, but it was just probably next to an executive building.
它看起来很棒，但可能只是在行政大楼旁边。
I've been like doing a little like, I've been dropping in on Seinfeld because it's on Netflix right now and I would, and I'd see what they did and I'd go, I can't believe they shot all those scenes, built all that stuff.
我一直想做点类似的事情，我一直在看《宋飞正传》，因为它现在在 Netflix 上，我会去看他们做了什么，我会去，我不敢相信他们拍摄了所有这些场景，建造了所有这些东西。
But you guys, I was looking at this episode going, oh my God, that's child's play.
但是你们，我看着这一集，天哪，这简直就是儿戏。
They were, they were going bananas on how I met your mother.
他们对我如何认识你母亲感到疯狂。
Yeah.
是的。
We went bananas.
我们发疯了。
We did not, no one was ever bored on how I met your mother and no one was resting on their laurels.
我们没有，没有人对我如何认识你母亲感到厌烦，也没有人安于现状。
It was like, we would do sometimes like 80 scenes in 21 and a half minutes.
就像，我们有时会在 21 分半钟内完成 80 个场景。
We would do it.
我们会这么做的。
And this one has plenty of that.
而这个就有很多这样的东西。
All those pops.
所有这些流行音乐。
All those jump rounds.
所有这些跳跃。
Yeah, all this fun little and the fun little flash forward things like even like when marshals like I'm gonna save tuck Oh fun land and then you go to all these spinning headlines of like the absolute terror that's gonna Talk of fun.
是的，所有这些有趣的小事和有趣的小闪现就像当法警像我要拯救塔克哦有趣的土地然后你就会看到所有这些旋转的头条新闻就像绝对的恐怖一样会谈论乐趣。
That's the most evil place on earth and this company is unbelievable evil It's just it's it's fun with editing and it's all it's all just right You know, we're we're writing it like editing jokes on the page, which is not how sign felt was written It's not how friends was written.
那是地球上最邪恶的地方，这家公司是令人难以置信的邪恶，只是编辑很有趣，一切都刚刚好你知道，我们像在页面上编辑笑话一样写它，这不是签名的感觉，这不是朋友的写法。
It's not how most sitcoms were written And we were joking at the, I think we did like 9,125 scenes in nine seasons.
大多数情景喜剧不是这样写的，我们开玩笑说，我认为我们确实喜欢九季中的 9,125 个场景。
How much a mother, something like that, Josh, if I remember in the number.
乔什，如果我记得号码的话，多少是一个母亲，类似的事情。
And we were like, I bet everybody loves Raymond door to door in 11 seasons did about 2,000 scenes, you know what I mean?
我们当时想，我敢打赌每个人都喜欢雷蒙德，他在 11 季中挨家挨户拍了大约 2000 个场景，你明白我的意思吗？
Because scenes were on those shows are like 15 pages long.
因为那些节目中的场景大约有 15 页长。
You're scenes with Marshall, like in the office, like those are longer how I met your mother's scenes and those are probably four pages long.
你和马歇尔在一起的场景，比如在办公室，就像那些更长的我如何遇见你母亲的场景，这些可能有四页长。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
But I think that the form of the sitcom was influenced by Neil Simon and Broadway, and it was plays that were transferred onto sound stages in some ways.
但我认为情景喜剧的形式受到了尼尔·西蒙和百老汇的影响，它是通过某种方式转移到摄影棚的戏剧。
All in the family is like a play.
一家人的一切都像一场戏。
It's a play.
这是一场戏。
Those scenes are probably 25 pages.
这些场景大概有 25 页。
You're just in the interior living room, go for 25 pages.
你就在室内客厅，读 25 页。
And I think that what was revolutionary for you guys was you took like Quentin Tarantino and you applied it to the sitcom.
我认为对你们来说革命性的是你们像昆汀·塔伦蒂诺一样，并将其应用到情景喜剧中。
Yes, it was much more like we were emulating Tarantino or like at the Simpsons, We were in an editing style that was not the sitcom, which was our mission statement.
是的，这更像是我们在模仿塔伦蒂诺或《辛普森一家》，我们采用的剪辑风格不是情景喜剧，这是我们的使命宣言。
We wanted to Trojan horse this thing into CBS that looked like it fit into King of Queens and two and a half men, but it was actually genetically nothing like that at all.
我们想把这个东西植入哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS），看起来像是《皇后之王和两个半男人》的特洛伊木马，但实际上它在基因上根本不是那样的。
I will say with the Seinfeld connection, Susie Greenberg, our producer, did produce all of Seinfeld and all of how I met your mother, so both shows were ambitious shows that she produced.
我要说的是，与《宋飞正传》的联系，我们的制片人苏西·格林伯格确实制作了《宋飞正传》的全部内容以及《我是如何遇见你母亲的》的所有内容，所以这两部剧都是她制作的雄心勃勃的节目。
old man.
老头儿。
He musted me, fell in love with you.
他必须我，爱上你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the hyper fixed podcast from RadioTopia.
这是来自 RadioTopia 的超级固定播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyper fixed pod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixed pod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials, back to shell.
广告结束，回到shell。
Hey, John, I have a question for you.
嘿，约翰，我有个问题要问你。
This is a little more like broad scope, but it's it's on theme for how I met your mother, which is so you and I met each other in 2001 or 2000, we haven't figured out both your babies, like baby actors.
这有点像宽泛的范围，但它的主题是我如何遇见你母亲，也就是说你和我在 2001 年或 2000 年认识，我们还没有弄清楚你的两个孩子，就像小演员一样。
And then Kind of like halfway between then and now there's how I met your mother and then we're now we're talking in a podcast and it's 20 Let's call it a quarter century lady later So it feels like when you're starting off and it's your first pilot your first series you're like I don't you don't even Thinking about a career you just want to get another job or get the job, but now we have what could You could call we have careers like we have a quarter century or even longer of acting being steadily employed were in, you know, a very small percentage of people have been able to do it this long.
然后有点像从那时到现在的中间，我遇见了你的母亲，然后我们现在在播客中交谈，现在是 20 岁了，我们称其为四分之一世纪后的女士所以感觉就像当你开始，这是你的第一个飞行员你的第一个系列你就像我不你甚至不考虑一个职业你只是想找到另一份工作或得到这份工作，但现在我们拥有你可以称之为的职业我们拥有像我们这样的职业你知道，只有极少数人能够做到这么长时间，他们已经稳定就业了四分之一个世纪甚至更长的时间。
Do you have some sense when you look back on your career, like, does it make some weird sense to you, or have you just been following the breadcrumbs along the way, or, because I always have the sense, like, the things that were meant for me came to me and the things that weren't didn't, like, I have a kind of spiritual detachment around the whole thing.
当你回顾自己的职业生涯时，你是否有一些感觉，比如，它对你来说有什么奇怪的意义吗？或者你只是一直在追随面包屑，或者，因为我总是有这样的感觉，比如，那些对我来说有意义的事情来到了我身边，而那些不适合我的事情却没有，比如，我对整个事情有一种精神上的超然。
Like, I'm just curious how you look at your career now.
就像，我只是好奇你现在如何看待你的职业生涯。
Man, okay, let's set up a separate podcast, but I think both, but lately, I've really let go as best I can.
伙计，好吧，让我们建立一个单独的播客，但我想两者都有，但最近，我真的已经尽我所能地放手了。
This idea that there's some road that I'm supposed to be following or that I'm supposed be creating.
这个想法是我应该遵循或者我应该创造一些道路。
Like, it's really, I'm so privileged, what will what will appear past that tree is what will appear and I will be.
就像，真的，我很荣幸，那棵树后面会出现什么，我就会出现什么。
And whatever it is, I will deal with it as gracefully as I can with enthusiasm.
不管是什么，我都会热情地尽可能优雅地处理它。
And what I get from that is what I put into it.
我从中得到的就是我投入的。
And I'm trying to do that, because I look back and I thought I was an engineer, I thought I was trying to go places, but that's not what was happening at all.
我正在努力做到这一点，因为我回顾过去，我以为我是一名工程师，我以为我正在尝试去一些地方，但事实并非如此。
Things were given to me, the opportunities showed up, and I did the best I could.
事情给了我，机会出现了，我尽力了。
I should actually be proud of that, that I did the best I could when things came up, I made friends and I tried to not hurt people's feelings along the way and you know what I'm saying?
我实际上应该为此感到自豪，当事情发生时我尽了最大努力，我交了朋友，我一路上努力不伤害别人的感情，你知道我在说什么吗？
Like for the most part and it is remarkable that I'm here still and I think I'll pat my back because I'm here with me.
就像大多数情况一样，值得注意的是我还在这里，我想我会拍拍我的背，因为我和我在一起。
But like you know that we're still here especially as I can't believe I've seen things change So much and I'm still here, you know, it's a remarkable.
但正如你所知，我们还在这里，尤其是当我不敢相信我看到事情发生了如此之大的变化而我还在这里时，你知道，这是一个了不起的事情。
We now can say like back in my day, like we actually had history enough to know like, oh, it hasn't always been done this way.
我们现在可以说，就像在我那个时代，我们实际上有足够的历史来知道，哦，事情并不总是这样做的。
When we came up, it was different.
当我们上来的时候，情况就不一样了。
There was a mind.
有一个想法。
Yes.
是的。
We had a my day.
我们度过了我的一天。
We totally.
我们完全。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, I think I brought this up on the pod.
你知道，我想我在 Pod 上提到了这个。
But E.L.
但 E.L.
Doctor of this novelist said writing a novel is like driving at night.
这位小说家的医生说写小说就像夜间开车。
You can only see three feet in front of you, but you can get the whole way there.
你只能看到前方三英尺，但你可以到达那里。
way.
方式。
And careers are a little like that.
职业生涯也有点类似。
Like you think like, Oh, I know where I'm going.
就像你想的那样，哦，我知道我要去哪里。
I'm going there.
我要去那里。
But the truth is you're just driving at night and you're just looking at where the headlights are illuminating.
但事实是，你只是在夜间开车，你只是看着车头灯照亮的地方。
And you're just trying to like, make it three feet, three feet, three feet, three feet.
你只是想把它变成三英尺，三英尺，三英尺，三英尺。
And then when you look back, I love that.
然后当你回头看时，我喜欢这样。
There is some sort of sense to it.
这是有某种意义的。
There is a kind of arc or a story.
有一种弧线或故事。
But it's like how we make your mother like that, that quote we talk about like, life only makes sense backwards, but you have to live it forwards.
但这就像我们如何让你的母亲变成那样，我们谈论的那句话就像，生活只有倒着走才有意义，但你必须向前生活。
Right.
正确的。
That was heavy and you just follow your instinct.
那很沉重，你只能跟随你的直觉。
Like honest to God, we watched Harold and Kumar.
老实说，我们观看了哈罗德和库马尔。
We went, those guys are all funny.
我们去了，那些家伙都很有趣。
Neil Patrick Harris seems good for Barney.
尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯似乎很适合巴尼。
And at some point, we're going to get John and Cal on the show.
在某个时候，我们会让约翰和卡尔出现在节目中。
And all of that happened just because we liked you.
而这一切的发生只是因为我们喜欢你。
And we remember that you made us laugh.
我们记得你让我们开怀大笑。
And it's rare, right?
而且很罕见，对吧？
You don't, you don't watch performances and just like laugh all the time.
你不，你不看表演，只是喜欢一直笑。
Like I just, you guys were so charming and funny in that movie, the chemistry, the three of you in in that car, we watched the scene of you and you, Kallen, Neil in the car, and then we created a TV show and had one by one, all of you on it.
就像我一样，你们在那部电影中是如此迷人和有趣，化学反应，你们三个在那辆车里，我们观看了你和你，卡伦，尼尔在车里的场景，然后我们制作了一个电视节目，并一一展示了你们所有人。
No, wild.
不，狂野。
And it's just like totally just like remembering that you made us laugh.
就像完全记得你让我们开怀大笑一样。
That was the science there.
这就是科学。
Well, that's the other thing to your point, Josh.
好吧，这是你的另一件事，乔什。
Like you think you're pushing your life in one way and you think at some point you were like, oh, that didn't work.
就像你认为你正在以一种方式推动你的生活，但你认为在某些时候你会觉得，哦，那不起作用。
But you were actually influencing the direction of your life, just in your career, just in ways that you weren't aware of.
但你实际上正在影响你的生活方向，只是在你的职业生涯中，只是以你没有意识到的方式。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like, there's, there is a sort of a path there, but it's not one that you're creating or that you're kind of in charge.
就像，那里有一种路径，但它不是你正在创建的或你负责的。
Yeah, it's almost like partnering with mysterious forces where some of it, you have agency around, you have control of what you say as to and over what you say no to, you have control over your conduct on set, like you said, like trying not to be a kind, good person to work with.
是的，这几乎就像与神秘力量合作，其中一些人，你周围有代理，你可以控制你说什么和你拒绝什么，你可以控制你在片场的行为，就像你说的，就像努力不成为一个善良的、好的共事者。
like you don't wanna be put in the life's too short category.
就像你不想被归入生命太短暂的类别一样。
But a lot of it is just, you know, strange, like you're depending on, in some ways, like the reason Craig wanted to cast all of you guys is because I think when you make someone laugh, there's this gratitude where you're like, thank you, life is hard, you made me laugh.
但很多事情只是，你知道，很奇怪，就像你在某种程度上依赖的那样，就像克雷格想要让你们所有人出演的原因一样，因为我认为当你让某人发笑时，你就会有一种感激之情，谢谢你，生活很艰难，你让我发笑。
You remember it.
你还记得吧。
You remember the feeling.
你记得那种感觉。
I remember that feeling.
我记得那种感觉。
Yeah.
是的。
The people that have made me laugh really hard, whether it's in life or in performance, like I have an like unending gratitude for them.
那些让我开怀大笑的人，无论是在生活中还是在表演中，我对他们都有无尽的感激之情。
Yeah.
是的。
I completely feel the same way.
我完全有同样的感觉。
And to piggyback on that, the comedic performance that I love, that I performers that I love the most, for some reason I'm convinced that they're selfless about it.
顺便说一句，我喜欢的喜剧表演，我最喜欢的表演者，出于某种原因，我相信他们对此是无私的。
Like they're not trying to be clever.
就好像他们不想表现得聪明一样。
They're not trying to convince you of anything.
他们并不想让你相信任何事情。
they're not trying to tell you that they're smart or anything, they're just trying to make that sound come out of your body.
他们并不是想告诉你他们很聪明什么的，他们只是想让你的身体发出这种声音。
And they'll do whatever takes it.
他们会不惜一切代价。
It's like music, it's pretty pure.
就像音乐一样，非常纯粹。
It's, yeah, when I sense that in a performer, I go, oh, I love you, you know, it's...
是的，当我感觉到一个表演者时，我会说，哦，我爱你，你知道，这是......
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
Well, we love you, John Cho.
好吧，我们爱你，约翰·赵。
We can't take it for your whole night.
我们不能忍受你整个晚上。
You were so nice to do this.
你能这么做真是太好了。
This was like, we were talking about the episode separately from this.
这就好像我们是在单独谈论这一集。
We're like, we gotta have John on here.
我们就像，我们必须让约翰在这里。
So I'm so, oh my God, I'm so glad that we did.
所以我很高兴我们这么做了。
Thank you for making the time.
感谢您抽出时间。
I know we had to go back and forth a little bit.
我知道我们必须来回走动。
Yeah, man.
是的，伙计。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
Great to see you, man.
很高兴见到你，伙计。
I hope to see you soon.
我希望很快就能见到你。
Thanks, guys.
谢谢，伙计们。
This is fun.
这很有趣。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
它由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 提供和分发。
This show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves，他是 blue studio 的一名成员，我们的 Gen Z 大师是我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg，副制作人是 Katherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《事情不是这样发生的》、《无论书在哪里》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substep.
你也可以在 Substep 上订阅我自己的亡父协会。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。